on espère qu'il va prétendre représenter
qui viendra sur le plateau et sachez que
c'est le président en vient on est en
train de travailler à même avant même de
le savoir sur un face à baba un petit
peu spécial alors à saveur alors c'est
pas un traitement de faveur aujourd'hui
bien sûr il va venir en tant que
candidat mais c'est c'est le président
voilà en fonction c'est le président de
la république de tous les français donc
forcément je pense que j'aimerais plus
le voir face à des français aujourd'hui
j'aimerais bien moi moi ce que
j'aimerais faire avec le président je le
dis j'aimerais le mettre face à toutes
les personnes qui ont jalonné son son
quinquennat c'est à dire un gilet jaune
le mettre face à une infirmière
exactement toutes les thématiques qui
l'a rencontré je pense ce serait
vraiment intéressant ces voix là c'est
ce que j'ai en tête s'il se présente
bien entendu s'il est candidat mais
vraiment je ne serai plus sur une
formule comme celle ci vraiment avec
toutes les personnes voilà fournit tous
les problèmes qu'il a re qui l'a
rencontré pendant son quinquennat plutôt
que de le mettre face à d'autres
candidats comme je peux le faire sur
l'ailé les autres les autres
protagonistes voilà parce que voilà je
pense que j'ai envie et je pense que
mine de rien les ans les français ont
envie de lui parler
des débats il va y en avoir sur les
autres chaînes à un moment il va devoir
voilà je sais qu'il veut pas faire le
débat du premier tour mais peut-être
qu'à un moment il va devoir quand même
voilà discuter avec valérie pécresse
wake eric zemmour avec ou avec jean luc
mélenchon avec d'autres voix la nouvelle
marine le pen oui mais c'est vrai que là
le voir face à des français qui ont
marqué son quinquennat c'est ce que
j'aimerais faire après pour l'instant il
n'est pas candidat donc voilà on fait
des plans sur la comète et on espère en
tout cas qui viendra oui pourquoi
l'émission face à baba sera
incontournable au lycée parce que la
grande crainte la grande inquiétude
l'interrogation c'est le vote des jeunes
alors pour qui ils vont voter peu
importe mais ce qu'ils vont voter et là
vous vous avec le public que vous avez
vous les passionnés à ce niveau là c'est
à dire que s'ils viennent ici ils auront
des téléspectateurs jeunes qu'ils
recherchent comme électeurs et comme
citoyen donc c'est pour ça que ça
devient incontournable émission
notamment et viendra pour south a repris
après oui oui il viendra pour ça aussi
mais parce que aussi c'est du direct les
vidéos avec mac line et carlitos et pas
du direct donc du coup c'est autre chose
un autre exercice limité à notre égard
je veux du direct parce que normalement
enfin même si on est d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec lui il est excellent en
direct et on a vu combien au programme
face à bath était accidentogènes où elle
a vu zemmour plutôt très bon et
mélenchon même si et très bon d'habitude
plutôt catastrophique à titre personnel
donc je pense qu'il est obligé de le
faire évidemment qu'on coûté on en
attend de moi lors à nice oui mais il
faut se demander aussi où se jouent
aujourd'hui une élection présidentielle
se joue un peu partout et ce sera un pas
en avant à une époque c'était un serrer
les mains sur des marchés ça se fait
encore mais c'est largement concurrencé
aujourd'hui par les médias et les
réseaux sociaux et votre émission au nom
tout cas au niveau quotidien et face à
la ba était quand même un succès qui a
été quand même très important c'est
l'émission quotidienne la plus regardée
donc c'est très important et je dirais
qu'il ya pas que les 18 25 ans qui
regardent il ya toute une frange de la
population et moi je moi comme je le dis
à chaque changement de la place de
personne je pense est très important de
faire les émissions politiques de france
télévision de tf1 des autres chaînes
voilà des siennes voilà d'information
mais c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
complémentaire et c'est autre chose
alors en jeu c'est que voilà tu es tu
t'y connais bien là dessus c'est vrai
que c'est ce que tu pense que le
président va venir toi si ce premier
jeu j'ai pas d'idée sur le sujet c'est
lui qui prendra cette décision je pense
qu'il n'a rien contre toi et rien contre
ce format là et il a fait 35 débat quand
même on le rappelle à l'école john en
vue mais allez voir sur youtube vous
allez voir où il est pendant 6 7 heures
face à des français debout il finit en
chemise parce qu'il est un peu de cette
heure c'est dur où il répond à toutes
les questions il ya parfois des
centaines de questions dont qui est tout
à fait apte à faire ça maintenant est ce
qu'il a envie de descendre dans l'arène
à ce point il a plus ou moins 10
pour le choix on a toujours le choix
des chiffres quoi ils parlent et se
permettent si les principaux robert
l'élection le futur c'est compliqué pour
lui de ne pas venir s'ils avaient marine
le pen valérie pellan la marine le pen
s'est bien battu d'après les répéter en
gros les cinq premiers lui ne peut pas
ne pas venir annonce à beckham oui quand
ils sont importants aussi c'est de
donner envie aux personnes de voter bien
sûr il faut dire aussi aux jeunes passer
ce message c'est que là vous avez le
choix de pouvoir vraiment à travailler
sur ce que vous avez envie d'avoir plus
tard donc il faut vraiment les embarquer
et je pense que votre émission elle
interpelle l est du coup se dire voilà
après aller voter ses conseillers des
piochs les chiffres tous les matins
c'est pas pour la beauté du geste mais
bon faire plaisir
sentir quelque chose qui a changé en
quelques mois avant que les politiques
venaient chez hanouna c'était pour se
donner une image plus cool maintenant
c'est vraiment pour toucher un autre
public et pour générer de l'engagement
jean luc mélenchon quand il est venu la
première fois dans btp il a généré plus
de 8000 adhésion je crois ce qui est
énorme donc comme l'a dit marie ne fait
pas la campagne elle va se jouer aussi
sur ce plateau alors je ne sais pas ce
que vous en pensez à les libérer
je trouve que le voc devrait être
obligatoire c'est-à-dire même blanc ce
qu'on veut mais on devrait être up en
vrai devoir regarder oui parce que je
n'aime pas les affaires de l'abstention
tout ça se règle tiens je voudrais quand
même dire que les mêmes blanc par
exemple
ma couleur préférée je voudrais dire que
le problème quand même c'est que au jour
d'aujourd'hui moi je suis pas capable
parce qu'on n'a pas donné les armes pour
on peut pas voter
complètement d'une manière autonome et
ça c'est pas recevable c'est à dire que
c'est pas normal il ya des machines à
voter qui existe c'est électronique ça
existe ça peut être focalisé sur et moi
ça marche à chaque fois je lis aux
assesseurs et il n'y a pas de nouveaux
heurts mais non mais non il n'y en a pas
c'est vrai je trouve ça trop souvent en
braille oui et un de mes rideaux fond de
certaines mairies de le fond résonneront
les tous les candidats auront
l'obligation d'avoir leur profession de
foi en facile à lire et à comprendre la
subira si la lyre à comprendre c'est
justement pour les publics qui sont
empêchés qui ont des déficiences
intellectuelles des problèmes de
compréhension loin je pense que ça
servira tout le monde fait valoir des
professionnellement facile à lire à
comprendre paroles de lire le braille
haut niveau au niveau des programmes
mais tu as raison qu'ils sont du travail